this week on quadriga
refugees in Germany angst on both sides
Europe is being confronted by record
numbers of refugees Germany takes on
more asylum seekers than any other
country in Europe in 2013 alone over
100,000 applications for asylum were
filed in Germany but not everyone is
ready to welcome refugees with open arms
this building in twiglets in eastern
Germany was recently fire bombed in what
authorities suspect was an attempt to
prevent 40 refugees from moving in
police say violence against refugee
homes like this is on the rise and
that's sending people like these
protestors onto the street they want
refugees to know they are still welcome
in Germany
what does German society need to do to
prevent future attacks your host this
week peter craven yes hello and a very
warm welcome to this latest edition of
quadriga coming to you from the German
capital Berlin and this time around the
focus is very much on the situation of
asylum seekers and refugees here in
Germany of course in light of that a
shocking attack in the small German town
of troglytes over the weekend on a
planned shelter for asylum seekers now
to talk about all these issues I'm
joined here in the studio by three
excellent commentators and without any
further ado I would like to introduce
them to you
beginning with Makonnen Ms gainer born
in Eritrea he's made Germany his second
home the colon is a freelance journalist
working in Germany and internationally
for a range of media outlets he's also a
political analyst at the Berlin based
high nourish Birth Foundation focusing
on migration and diversity we're also
joined by Christiane Jakob who has been
working for the Berlin based daily the
tats for a decade now specializing on
issues like migration social movements
and development he's also co-authored a
book on fortress Europe closing its
doors to refugees and a very familiar
face here on quadriga
Judy Dempsey currently a writer and
analyst for the Carnegie Foundation Judy
has worked for a host of international
broad
in a long and distinguished career thank
you very much all three for joining me
today and I'd like to begin with you
Christian because I've mentioned already
we saw it in our short reports at the
beginning this fire this arson attack as
it apparently is in the small town of
true glitz in eastern Germany it's a
great cause for concern it's made the
international headlines you have been to
throat lit and I'd like to ask you to
describe true glitz for us so that we've
got an idea of what kind of place this
is that we're talking about actually
twiglets is a typical East German
village it's very small and the
southernmost tip of the federal state of
zaxon unheard about half an hour south
of leipzig and it has lost about 25
percent of its population in the last
seven years which is also typical for
rural areas in the east of Germany until
now twiglets has not received any
refugees despite of the high amount of
refugees coming into Germany but then
the regional governor government decided
to send a small amount of refugees 40
were supposed to go to twiglets and live
there during their asylum case was was
checked by the authorities and since
December in an initiative of local
citizens started to protest against this
and at the beginning it was only
citizens of the village but after a few
weeks members and activists of the
neo-nazi party NPD joined the protests
and mingled with the locals to protest
against the refugees that were supposed
to come and this protest escalated so
far that they were even threatening the
mayor of twiglets and after a few weeks
he resigned he decided to not be mayor
anymore because he said that the
government the German government is not
able to protect him and that was the
point when twiglets for the first time
came into national news everybody was
curious what is happening there how is
it possible that that these people were
able to threaten the representative of
the state and for doing something that
is like completely consensual to an
extent that he says I can't do my job
anymore
and why this discussion was going
in the last week's the attack on the
shelter took place last Friday what
details can you give us just I'm using
your you as a reporter here because
you've actually been there just what
details can you give us about this arson
attack as it appears to be yeah it's not
known yet who actually did it there is
nothing like as nobody claimed to have
done it yet and the police is the police
said that they were doing investigations
into all directions not only in the
radical right-wing milieu but it's very
likely that that some way or the other
it's the the the ones who committed it a
part of often of extremist group it
would not be the first time there has
been several increase of attacks like
this on refugee shelters on refugees
particularly in East Germany in rural
areas of East Germany and in most cases
the police is not able to investigate
who did it and the difference this time
was that only few hours after after it
happened the public attention grew very
very quickly the head of the federal
state of Saxony a tryna hassle of did
the press conference which is very
unlikely normally it's only the
president of the police was doing it and
the same afternoon he together with the
Ministry Minister for interior affairs
of Saxon Anna came personally to talk
leads to join the demonstration of
citizens of the village and well that's
that's something new mmm-hmm mokona and
I'd like to ask you for your impressions
about all this because it is it's it's
an unbelievable story that the mayor is
forced to step down there's been a death
threat against another official what do
you make of it all well I would like to
state at the beginning just two simple
observations one is that drug leads is a
symptom of a long tradition and an ugly
tradition of hatred and brutality
against refugees and minorities in this
country the second thing is drug leads
is everywhere
only this year only the first quarter of
this year the last three months we had
over 20 attacks against refugee refugees
and refugee homes so we see here it's
not a single issue in trade elites but
it is within a long tradition starts
back in the 90s but also during the 19
2014 last year when we had a growing
number of refugees it's very true that
Germany has been receiving the biggest
number of refugees in Europe but at the
same time the awareness is growing also
empathy is growing but also racism and
hatred is a kind of on work this time
and there is a European a kind of on
vogue you say it's like a fashion it's
yes it's a fashion I mean you can see in
many European countries look into France
looking Denmark look UK you have growing
sentiments of fear mongering and hate
mongering against refugees and
minorities and in Germany you have a
growing not only those disadvantaged not
only those less educated but you have
also a middle class growing potential
who has been campaigning against
refugees and minorities and of course
with within the framework of anti
Islamic campaign etc so you know there's
there's a lot of package into that but
refugees are part of that fear and hate
mongering as well you've given us an
awful lot to talk about you two
gentlemen first of all Jew Judy I'd like
to turn to you Heiko Maas the German
justice minister has reflected what you
were just saying that he said this is
turbulence is the tip of the iceberg
what is the iceberg if this is the tip
of the iceberg well and the iceberg is a
very very solid piece of unspoken
narrative and it's about Germany trying
to come to terms with being a country of
migration
it's about Germany trying to come to
terms with the
fact that this has to keep its doors
open and I think above all it's it's
about Germany particularly Germany it's
the biggest of the European Union
countries in the strongest economy
coming to terms with the extraordinary
complexities of globalization and the
crises now that so many that
particularly Germany and other
governments in the EU are facing across
the Middle East across even the Caucasus
across parts of Africa and as these
crisis which are coming up against this
iceberg which it was before was more or
less stable despite what you see it was
more or less stable but now
now comes the the crunch time on how
Germany is going to deal with this
problem
when Germany tries to tackle when
Germany wrestles with the kind of issues
that you've both been talking about is
is the situation in Germany because you
were mentioning Denmark France and other
UK in other countries is that process of
tackling these problems different in
Germany because of Germany's history
than it is in the other countries I
actually think I'm thinking of this
quite a lot over the past couple of days
I think is this actually quite
remarkable how Chancellor Angela Merkel
and and the German government has
stepped in from very early on against
Islamophobia against hate against the
Muslim communities against anti-semitism
against against anybody who's against
keeping Germany a place of welcome it is
remarkable and I don't think Merkel is
doing this for reasons or it's my duty I
think she actually believes in it and
she has tried to she has tried to
prevent her own party her conservative
party it's in coalition with the Social
Democrats but she's try to prevent her
government from verging are a pandering
to populist parties such as the Earth
Day and I mean I think and this actually
I think this thing goes about compared
to how the British government deals with
immigrants and refugees and indeed other
countries across Europe hats off
actually to this government for taking a
stance from the beginning okay some
praising work yeah I totally agree that
I think Angela Merkel at the first
Chancellor who gave the issue of
immigration the issue of integration
one of her priority attention that's
it's it's very remarkable on the other
side there's some unique situation in
Germany and it is a narrative you know
this country it has been always told
that Germany hasn't been an immigration
country it's an ethnic nation you know
being German is always something you
know attached to ethnicity to whiteness
etc etc so Germany has been has a
difficulty in defining itself as a
republic you know as a modern Republic
state with people coming immigrating and
you know being part of the citizenship
of this country so this notion of
citizenship based on Republic is still
very difficult in the narrative of
Germany it's an evolving process
exactly I I wonder I wonder about that
actually it's interesting to hear your
perspective I think Germany has changed
over this idea of migration actually
this was a furious debate in 1992-1993
the Social Democrats wanted to actually
get rid of this German citizenship
nationhood idea through blood your
mother or your grandmother had to have
german blood or whatever i mean i think
i think that the base has changed for
many reasons I think Germany has become
more open through globalization but
secondly Germany needs immigrants for
demographic reasons and she's true quite
frankly it is hugely still largely in
white society but the integration
element is now top of the agenda the the
need to reach out to the second third
and fourth generations of Young Turks
the need to make the Muslims literally
feel welcome through the toleration of
mosques and building it I think Germany
is making that transition from from from
in denial about the need for immigrants
to the necessity for them okay so that's
also that's good news about Germany yeah
but I want to come back to the point
that mikonam made that talking about the
the problem at hand with fur glitz yeah
and and and the broader problem behind
that because you mentioned the
statistics you mentioned that these but
these attacks are on the rise I've
the figures yeah in 2012 there were 24
attacks on Asylum shelters around
Germany 2013 that figure was up to 58
2014 until the beginning of the week the
figure was 150 but suddenly went up to
160 that apparently the authorities 162
had registered for last year it's on the
rise yeah why is it on the rise is it
simply because more and more refugees
are coming to Germany as you appear to
indicate or is it more complex than that
hmm Christie oh well I would say that it
has been clear that this was going to
happen the question was only how quick
was it going to rise and it's true that
the logic it was going to happen the
experiences of the 1990s when the number
of asylum seekers was at a similar level
as it is now I still they are many of
the of the political structures did not
change it is true that the German
society has modernized a lot and many
people are aware of that there is no
innocence so to say in the asylum and
immigration debate the attacks the
murderer murders of asylums asylum
seekers and immigrants in the early 90s
are still are still very very aware in
the in the public and talked about in
the last in the last couple of weeks
I've been looking back to that period
and Sonia then there was a series of
Nazi terrorism in the last one and a
half decades that has been revealed in
2012 of the anti so-called NSU and the
reaction of explain from view as a
terrorist cell working out of East
Germany who killed a large number of
immigrants over a long period of time
and went completely undiscovered by the
authorities we're not quite sure why did
they have a blind eye to the racist
motives we don't know but obviously that
has been a major issue in this whole
debate as well about immigration and
integration and what this did did change
the German society and there is a
difference to the 1990 that the
difference is now that there is no more
right-wing hegemony in the
rural areas in East Germany you now have
both both sides even in small villages
as toilets you have people who are
completely kind of phobic who don't want
foreigners to come in and to also open
the opposed it but you also have people
you have initiatives who say we want
foreigners we say welcome to immigrants
and that's a big difference this has not
been the case in the 1990s and that
something new and that's the good thing
about this transition in German society
again Makoni Roberto yeah of course
there's a lot of paradox see and in the
narrative and then the official politics
so while we see a clear change and
policy shifts in the in the official
policy like the citizenship law and also
the you know like defining Germany as an
immigrant country and the demographic
shift etc is a lot of issue into that
and changing labor market so there is a
lot of truth set but at the same time we
have a growing diversity within the
society and immigrants are no more
silent you know they voice racism and
that is one of the deep-rooted problem
of Germany yeah there is a deep-rooted
racism which has been shown not only in
the official politics but also like if
you look into the job market if you look
into education if you look into the
career if we look into the political
representation you know that is the gap
when I'm talking about you know we have
the official political shift on the one
side but you have also huge racism
discrimination in the day daily life we
are also in the institutions but then
again you have also growing sentiments
of fear and hate mongering against
refugees so that that's that's that's
what you see on the one side raised a
growing empathy towards refugees
activists who go to the streets and also
show a lot of sympathy but also even in
the politics there is a shift that that
the politics believes today that Germany
should take more share and also
responsibility towards refugees but then
again we shouldn't create
more attraction to refugees so it's like
how do you deal with who came in treat
them like more human on the other side
protect the borders and building a
fortress around Germany and Europe this
is something we're going to have to talk
about yeah because that's in it that's
obviously a core issue in this debate as
well yeah let's just go back to true
glitz though Judy I don't I don't want I
don't want to create the wrong
impression that it's important that in
every part of the world in part in in in
all the parts of Germany there's good
bad and in between but I think it would
be naive not to talk about the fact that
there are concentrations of far-right
anti-foreign a sentiment in eastern
Germany yes that's an issue why first of
all why are there these pockets why is
there a problem that is it's pronounced
in other parts of Germany as well but
it's very pronounced in eastern Germany
why it's particularly pronounced nation
Germany one historically it was a closed
society very much until the war Alton's
have fallen to Berlin Wall in 1989 under
the communist regime it was literally
closed foreigners such as they were I
found guest workers they were from
Vietnam even then they were living in
quasi ghettos this is the first thing
secondly it's hard to it's hard to play
down the enormous sociological shifts
that took place in East Germany during
the 1990s an apartment the fact that it
packed large space of Industry was
closed down to this enormous exodus of
young people particularly women women as
soon as they left school as soon as they
left college they got out as fast as
this could the opportunities were in
what western Germany are even outside
Germany and what you had then was
actually an older generation getting
older without a perspective without jobs
and a younger generation of young men
not particularly well educated and they
had nowhere to go and they became highly
vulnerable and so there's no doubt and
if if you travel to some of the towns
and villages in Brandenburg either they
are empty or they are with just very old
men very old people and young men
hanging around and just waiting to be
reaching for a cause and so it's
tragically it's easy for which the NPD
that's the the for rising party from
part of western Germany have gone in to
manipulate some people also say the more
population these areas lose the more
difficult it becomes for the remaining
citizens to accept any change and they
are not happy that new people come in
but they rather regard them as something
that makes their village even change
more that's very interesting the info or
at least one interesting question that
is a again you've been to triplets and
I'm the idea now is that the the as you
as you pointed out the I we were going
to be sending forty asylum seekers to
troglytes
that isn't going to happen now in the
immediate future although some families
have said they will begin to take people
and my question is would you recommend
asylum seekers to go and live intro
glitz if that was their future as
envisioned by German bureaucracy
actually in Germany asylum seekers
cannot decide on their own where they
want to live for the theoretically I
would rather prefer to to to respond
differently it's the government who
decides where they have to live for the
first months during their asylum
applications being checked and the
regional authorities make it made it
very clear on Saturday that they were
still going to send refugees to twiglets
that they were not going to accept that
the situation was too bad and they
cannot live there and I think this is
very this is was the correct decision
and it's the government's put a
obligation and responsibility to protect
them Lacombe what would you say that
would you say to Eritrean asylum seekers
arriving in Germany it's okay you can go
to throg let see it's okay you can go to
Eastern Germany no worries
I wouldn't recommend from the
perspective of a strong Democratic
Democratic state yes we shouldn't give
up
we shouldn't collapse in this situation
and you know like show strength and also
show when I like a principle
step and approach towards you know like
this brutality and hate which has been
shown and also the arson attack in from
that perspective we shouldn't give up
but from the perspective of a refugee a
single individual refugee I wouldn't
recommend to go to the troglytes because
otherwise you know they would have been
instrumentalized for politics for
political reasons yeah you know if they
are not there what the Nazi Party I know
is Nikoli cleaned areas so-called
nationally liberated areas with no
foreigners living in it and once the
government says okay it's too dangerous
we cannot send anybody there if they got
what they wanted I understand but in the
individual perspective like facing
day-to-day racism living with racist
atmosphere it shouldn't be the whole
population of troglytes but it's enough
if there are few races you know like who
make life to hell I was talking about
the role in all this of the NPD we've
mentioned if the far-right NPD party
that has obviously had an instrumental
role in what has been happening
interrogates we don't know whether these
are people from the village itself which
they are in part or people from the area
or people from either even further
afield I'd like to introduce a new voice
to the discussion somebody who's not
here so a lot of applause the former
head of the German of the Council of
Jews here in Germany I think she was in
that post through to 2010 or so and
she's a woman who knows a thing or two
about persecution because she had to
hide away from the Nazis as a child were
during the Nazi period here in Germany
and she came out of the weekender in
response to the to the arson attack on
the asylum shelter in progress and she
said the following the NPD party the
party has to be banned as quickly as
possible is she right
if no I don't think so one if you ban a
party it goes underground and becomes
invisible and insidious let them stand
and let them be counted for and see them
secondly there is another factor that
actually it's just not supporters of the
NPD that are anti-racist and don't want
this country to be open to foreigners
the so-called bourgeois respectable
alternative for Deutschland half day is
playing into this kind of populism as
well and actually if you look at the
results of the NPD in in regional
elections it's got less and less her
support for the or anything indeed and I
have day is now is what you said
breaking the taboo that you can actually
talk about immigration and and having
opening up Germany to foreigners so I
mean it's it's very easy to say yes ban
when something is bad banners but I mean
they were they have been elected
democratically and there's less visible
to put something into the underground
now I think it encourages even more
people to slip down underground and make
life even more difficult for foreigners
would you say McConnell a ban or not I
totally understand your arguments but I
think and my problem is that this party
has been offering structures for
extremist activities so you know all the
groups who has been banned or who don't
have the legal structure to to to do
their hate and brutal activities and so
on you know like they they are under
this umbrella shadow of MPD so MPD
hasn't been only a party only a
political party but also its sheltering
a lot more brutal and neo-nazi and also
all these skinhead groups who has been
doing all these activities under the
shelter of under the umbrella umbrella
of exactly MPD so getting public money
and it's probably funny yes they are
publicly represented yes yeah exactly
okay we talked just a little while ago
about
about continuities and discontinuities
in in recent German history in the last
couple of decades I'd like to just give
you a couple more facts I'd like to go
back to the 1990s and mention some some
towns and cities in Germany that are
very resonant people think about what
happened back then Hoyas van de 1991 in
eastern Germany nights of rioting around
an asylum shelter just as similar to the
kind of things we're seeing now myrn
1992 three dead in an arson attack on
two turkish houses hauling a 1993 five
dead in a similar attack and then there
was an there was rioting in Rostock in
1992 let's have a look at that before we
talk about it August 1992 for three days
a racist mob held an apartment complex
in Rostock in northern Germany under
siege the complex was home to a number
of asylum seekers the crowd which at
times numbered several hundred attacked
the building with rocks and Molotov
cocktails around three thousand people
stood by while the riot ranged and many
even cheered the right-wing mob on
despite the intense violence no one was
killed in the multi-day assault but
elsewhere not all victims were so lucky
similar racially motivated attacks on
refugee homes in Germany claimed several
lives instead of placing the blame at
the feet of attackers many German
politicians blame the rising number of
refugees for the violence several months
after the attacks the German parliament
placed new restrictions on who could
apply for asylum in Germany
Christiaan I'd like to ask you to what
extent Germany is the same place as it
was then and to what extent it is a
different place I would say that
concerning the immigration debate
Germany has changed a lot this also
reflects in in the laws and the
immigration laws they in 1992 we had a
record of asylum claims several hundred
thousand and in that time practically
all parties decided to make it much more
difficult to claim asylum in Germany and
the effect was that in the Latin the
following 15 years the number of
refugees declined by about 95% and this
has changed this has changed since 2007
the number of refugees is going up again
and after almost two decades of
campaigning against vericsson of phobic
asylum laws the government has finally
agreed to change to change some of these
laws so now nowadays refugees are
getting almost the same social welfare
money as as Germans get it which was not
the case for many years restrictions on
the freedom of movement have been have
been loosed have been lose my eased
restrictions on the possibility to work
have been really relieved a bit and the
question if it stays like that because
now we're in a situation that the effect
of of of these changings the refugees
are benefiting from it but at the same
time the number the numbers are growing
and many people not only from the
right-wing AFT party but also from the
Miyake party are saying they are simply
too many we have to do something against
it and the the the the so to say the
recipe is to make the situation harder
clarity's i mentioned at the beginning
that you have written a book about
fortress Europe as you put it in the
book and it's it's a term that's used a
lot about refugee policy in Europe given
what you're saying to what extent is
Germany part of that fortress Europe or
not part of that fortress Europe Germany
is the most at the biggest and most
powerful state of the European Union as
the leading role
in the asylum policy of the European
Union and what Germany did was it
externalized its its border protection
to the countries on the border of the EU
and beyond tit we have seen a huge
development of externalization of border
protection now the German borders are
not only protected in the airport of
Frankfurt or on the border to Poland but
on the Greek Turkish border on the
Spanish Moroccan border in Lampedusa we
have we have an asylum architecture that
makes it extremely difficult for asylum
seekers to reach the center of Europe to
reach Germany and still the immigration
pressure is very high and therefore a
lot of people do come they try to find a
way around it around all these
instruments and institutions that have
been erected to prevent refugees from
arriving and to push the the burden to
countries like Italy to countries like
Greece main opponent it did work well
for a while but now after the Syrian
crisis and after the Eritrean the
increase of influx from Eritrea many and
also from the Balkan states many people
arrived in Germany
unless Germany and despite the fact that
Germany has been doing a lot of effort
to prevent this okay thanks but people
also come because countries like Italy
and so I just fed up by this Dublin
regulations and so on so they you know
they don't stick to those regulations
but also they break actually European
agreements like Dublin to w3 because
they say you know like you are
externalizing your border protection but
also not burden sharing with us so why
should we keep why should we you know
like adhere to the Shura peon
regulations if you don't do that
these are big difficult moral questions
they have a moral dimension this is the
European dimension of the whole
immigration but you have strong views on
this what is surprising
officially the German government doesn't
call for a revision of Dublin to Dublin
to the Dublin to convention essentially
means that any refugee that the first
the first country you country of which a
refugee lands that country is
responsible for registering that person
and lucky as its asylum claims and so on
what happens is that the Greeks are fed
up with this the Italians are fed up
with this the challenge have been
turning a blind eye because of the huge
pressure of immigrants but their own
populist agenda as well and the under
refugees get on the train get up to
Germany go across to other countries as
well and what it shows is that really
this is really good time just scrapped
Dublin - it's unfair for countries like
Greece initially to take the burden
they're the first call naturally and to
have a real system of burden sharing but
frankly this debate about burden sharing
has been going on for so long it shows
that there's an inherent unwillingness
to actually deal with the refugee and
Asylum issue what is gonna happen in the
near future in the medium term happen
doctor medium term we have the problem
right now there has to be burden sharing
and the German government and Dutch
government and actually all the 28
governments shouldn't really put away
all the pressures of populist agendas
and sit down say let us do burden
sharing has been a shift in the German
position in the last half year because
for almost one and a half decades
Germany has benefited from the
regulation as it was because the number
of refugees coming in where was lower as
the number it would have to take
according to its size but in the third
quarter of 2014 the number has risen
above this line and since then Germany
is saying oh actually who might have to
think about the new distribution team in
and just one little point on this
Germany when when the Greeks the Greek
asylum system is just so appalling even
before the Greek crisis how refugees
were treated put into prison and beaten
up in the streets police with connivance
of the police and friendly arrived in
germany and under the dublin - you meant
to send them back to Greece Germany
refused to
because the conditions are just so
appalling so it needs two things in my
view a revision of Dublin - but an
entire serious overhaul of the of the
Asylum structures in these countries and
a clearly Greece cannot deal with this
but actually Greece can't use us an
excuse not to deal with it either okay
point taken
meanwhile the situation is that the
number of asylum seekers in Germany
surged by about sixty percent last year
the authorities are saying they're
expecting 300 thousand asylum seekers
here in Germany this year other people
credible voices are saying maybe as many
as 500,000 600,000 my question is and
many people here in Germany will be
asking this question are all these
people who are coming here and applying
for asylum becoming refugees are they
here to stay
should they be here to stay well there
are different regulations and
conventions they are not all coming on
the basis of asylum law article 16 but
there is also the Geneva Convention the
anti anti told torture convention and
the European Human Rights Convention
zone so there are a number of issues why
people may come may be able to stay or
not to stay but also we should also tell
that a big number of people also leave
Germany for many reasons last year
around two hundred fifty seven thousand
former refugees and also Salim seekers
left Germany so we tell all the time the
one story about incomers and very
interesting and important point is you
tell us about these people who are
living why are they leaving and where
are they going to people live for many
reasons you know like they they come
here because they look for better
perspectives opportunities refugees are
as people as everybody where people like
every other immigrant looking for
themselves for their families children
and so on to have better perspectives
and if they recognize that all these
perspectives are not given then they
look for other
opportunities in other countries like
Sweden
UK Canada yes you then again because if
you go on the internet or you look at
government publications you can find all
sorts of sites and pamphlets and
information saying that Germany has a
very common school tour a welcoming
culture and open arms policy as it were
what you what you're saying appears to
suggest that Germany doesn't have a
welcoming culture well I mean Germany
the official politics say itself they
don't they don't have so far welcoming
politics or policy it's just you know
like in process that politics in Germany
say we need to have a welcoming centers
welcoming policy if you look into the
Auslander bird you know like this
immigration authorities you know it's I
mean it's it's horrible it's a that's
why many people try to be citizens as
soon as possible so they get rid of all
this very hardship and all the
initiatives around Germany that we have
seen that there's been a lot of you know
media coverage of church initiatives for
example tell me about those initiatives
I mean people out there need to know
about that it's what Christian was
saying earlier in fact it tends to be
consensus here that what is curious and
and very interesting is that by the
number of refugees and asylum seekers
has risen here in Germany the number of
civil society movements has risen as
well so the backlash isn't all in there
in the hands of the NPD and the
alternative for Deutschland and it is
remarkable younger people and older
people but particularly younger people
are going out on the streets and saying
no this is our country and as we're
going to make it welcome and this this
civil society has been traditionally
weak actually in Germany leaving aside
the shooting movements of the night of
the late 1960s but if this is something
very very new and something very
important and along with the church's
trade unionist step and that's another
issue but young people and older people
have gone out to the streets and said no
we don't want Germany to be closed and
wants to be open and I think also
because they're well informed they can
actually see what is happening in our
southern and eastern neighborhoods hmm
we saw that during the last couple of
I think you know like while we had on
the one side all these pegida movement
and so on and then on the other side
there were counter movements anti-racist
movements in many cities so the people
got numbered actually did the fact that
there were demonstrations and counter
demonstrations did that leave you
feeling more or less optimistic about
Germany and its future on the whole
issue of integration and immigration
well especially in bigger cities you
feel that diversified society where you
have the feeling that you know in these
in this areas in these regions it can't
happen that hate would be taking more
space and power but then on the other
side we have regional selective
situation like in eastern part of
Germany in the West and that's something
which disturbs me still you know we have
we have like cities like interestin
where things could be established
although there are also counter
movements then you have Western cities
where all these racist movements has
been very limited and also very
marginalized so yes I would feel that if
we have a broader movement of
anti-racist movement all over Germany
but all in all I think especially in
cities the the diversification of the
society is more livable so very people
feel that we're running out of time
quickly Christiana I'd like to just give
we began with you we began with you in
the actual little village town of true
glitz and I'd like to sort of take you
back to true bliss and invite you to in
30 seconds so tell me what is the way to
move forward
intro glitz to avoid the kind of things
that have been happening happening again
in the future I would say that one very
important thing is you have a
institutional reflection on this civil
society movement saying welcome to the
refugees which is very important and
very good but it's also necessary to do
the necessary laws to change the laws to
make it possible for people to come here
to arrive without
going through the through the
Mediterranean Sea and you have to
strengthen civil society movements on
the ground in these little villages not
only in the big cities but also in the
rural areas okay Christian thank you
very much for that thank you both as
well thank you all three for being here
today we've been discussing refugees in
Germany angst on both sides I hope we've
given you some food for thought if
you've enjoyed the show come back next
week bye bye for now and choose
you